من جهتها قالت مندوبه دوله قطر لدى الامم
المتحده علياء احمد بن سيف الثاني ان
الوضع الانساني في غزه والانتهاكات الارقه
للقانون الدولي في القطاع وانعكاساته
الخطيره على امن واستقرار المنطقه يتطلب
وقفا فوريا لاطلاق النار كما اكدت ان قطر
تدين تصريحات المسؤولين الاسرائيليين بشان
تهجير سكان
غزه ولقد كررت دوله قطر ادانتها لكل اشكال
استهداف المدنيين والمرافق المدنيه
وممارسه العقاب الجماعي وحرمان المدنيين
من الغذاء والماء والدواء وانتهاك حقوقهم
ومحاولات التهجير القصري كما تدين تصريحات
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين بشان تهجير سكان
غزه التي تعد امتدادا لنهج الاحتلال
وازدراء خطيرا للقوانين الدوليه وتقطع
الطريق امام فرص
السلام السيد الرئيس نرحب بالخطوات
المتخذه لتنفيذ قراري المجلس
و220 بما في ذلك تعيين السيده سيجرت كاج
في منصب كبير منسق الشؤون الانسانيه
واعاده الاعمار مؤكدين ضروره التنفيذ
الكامل لكل احكام هذين القرارين وفي الوقت
نفسه نؤكد ان الحاله الانسانيه الفادحه
والانتهاكات السافر للقانون الدولي
والمخاطر الجسيمه على الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه تحتم الدعوه لوقف اطلاق نار فوري
فذلك وحده يكفي الوضع حد لل الماساه
وتجنيب المنطقه تصعيدا
خطيرا